ん
皆さんバランスボールはご存じでしょう体のバランスを期待の体幹を鍛える
ボールのほどでございますで今回ことでたくさん準備してるんですけどもがあることが
したくて
バランスボールを買いましたえドラゴン号車バランスボールでなんでしっかと言います
とこういうバランスをとるのがよくあるんですけどこの誰とすべていくんだよ
以下やってみましょうはあああっ
尿糖に凍っては公益と潰れるんですよこうやってっ
これ徒歩でで深くであるとこうなります
を絶今が館図みたいにバランスボールに凍ってズっていくとボールの転がりを利用して
ローリング機能を使ってこのままずーっと行きですよ今フタ付であれだけ移動できたん
でもしこれを大量のバランスボールで行ったら一回のスライディングで7.5メートル
弱初メートル分くらいスライディングできる釣りかと思ったのでちょっと行けバランス
はれて今回それを実験してると思いますよゐここ
の時
私はまだ知らなかったこの後に起こる時期を
ソースね
僕は
できると思っていました
出来るか出来ないか分からない
そういうことを
一つずつ
クリアしていきたいですねあのもう一番不満言ったらクリアです1回のスライディング
で7m 辛いてきたことになるのであ勢いがポイントかな
あとは責めないことを祈ってやってみましょう以後できます
me
あきらめたらあ
夫馬て終了じゃないですか
その先にあるかができを
みたいですね女装が足りないんじゃもっとスピード重視でいきましょう
ああああああ
yao 選ぶ常に
のバランスおり家族を向いていっ
でもう1回コップ買っちゃうから苦労していくためにに声永井も声です
もうね卒業ちょっとこれでと言いますとっていきます
バーン
忘れないからこそ
とっ
そういうのを
ていきたいですね
上田ねはず滑れば難しいと思うんでやっぱり多分上が一番僕は良いと思いました
ちょっと上を狙っていきましょう走ってみますよ
youtube の
星になりたいな
持っています
me
はぁ
青山ます
ん
やばかっ
me
ええええええ
car
あっはぁ
ちょっとまあければ滑るから一平これでやってみましょう
2月だと球安定感があるのでこれならいけると思いますできます
後年
ん
はっはっはライター
以外こそ挟ん頭蓋骨2